hello everybody
um so this set of slide is on the
organization of this course
um you know as part of the syllabus i'll
explain uh how the course is structured
how you participate
how you've been created um and i give
you some details and you know where to
find
proper pointers um to get started
um this class will be taught in an
inverted classroom or flipped
classroom setting and it's going to be
online only
so we will not have in-person
opportunities to discuss
there's a second video where i just
briefly talk about the strategy of
the university classroom and and the
benefits
what you are typically used for as
lectures is
organized solely in short videos um
where i discuss
concepts or methods um the ideas also
include
um a few short questions for you your
own self elimination and we'll pick up
those questions then later
in visitation sessions so when you meet
tuesdays and thursday
we have time to answer your questions we
have time
to go through those problems
and hopefully have a good discussion the
recitations
are also used for another concept which
i explained on a later slide
which is your presentation of a specific
paper
this is part of your homework set
um is to find a paper to discuss with me
whether or not it fits into this that
schedule and together with a partner
have a short discussion of this paper
so we'll use this tuesday and thursday
sessions for this purpose
um in addition there's going to be an
office hour on friday so one hour where
i'm just
going to be connected to zoom meeting
you can log in at any time
um and we'll discuss whatever you want
to talk about um
for that there's going to be a doodle
poll which i'll post
during the first or at the time of the
first class um and then we
will find the best possible time for
everybody involved
um you know the course evaluation or
your evaluation in this course will be
made up fifty percent out of homework
because there's going to be
um six psets going to be posted um
one will be forgiven so i basically
count five psets and each
uh will allow you to accumulate
eight points um the paper presentation i
was talking
about i will have 20 points
we are talking about a 20-minute
presentation of a paper it's really a
summary of a paper
of your choice together with 10 minutes
of q and a
again this has been done in two groups
so you have to split up
the aspect of presenting preparing and
presenting
and then also when it comes to the
response
questions and then there's going to be
two short oral exams
this is 20 minutes so the actual exam is
only going to be
15 minutes um with the teaching staff so
this
is justin and myself maybe ask you a
couple of questions and just
make sure that you are on top of contact
we discussed in the weeks
prior um so there's two the first one
deals with the particle physics context
and the second one with the nuclear
physics
and um experimental methods as well
the grading scheme will not be worse
than what i'll give you here
so there is a great divide that's a
great divide but a great divide
at 85 between a and b seventy percent
between
e and c sixty percent between c and d
and below fifty percent earnest unf i
don't think anybody will get into this
environment as long as they participate
you